[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Hoş geldiniz
aranızda yemek kariyeri ile ilgilenenler
var mı hiç
yemekle ilgili herhangi bir şey yapmak
isteyen gastronomi ile ilgili
o zaman çıkın Ben kendi kendime
anlatacağım
şimdi bu konuşma için bana geldiklerinde
çok ilgimi çekti oyun
oyun yani
düşünmemiştim Ama gerçekten buraya
Sabahtan beri dinliyorsunuz
konuşmacıları
Muhtemelen onlar da söyledi Ben
dinlemedim bilmiyorum son bir kişiye
katıldım oyun hayatım ta kendisi
baktığın zaman
Şöyle bir düşündüm Ne anlatacağım
gittiğimde
Ne konuşacağım
kendimle ilgili bir gerçeği keşfettim
Evet bir oyun içinde değiliz ama benim
bu oyuna motive eden şey saygıydı saygı
duyuyorum ben beni izleyenlere benim
yemeğimi yapanlara ve beni dinleyenlere
en önemlisi
çarşıdan Manavdan aldığım sebzeye saygı
duyuyorum ona çok saygı duyuyorum ve bu
oyunda beni bu saygı çok motive ediyor
yani
bütün çocuklar oyun oynamayı sever değil
mi oyun oynamayı sevmeyen çocukluk
geçiren herhalde aramızda yoktur
uyandığım her zaman hepiniz gibi oyun
oynamak için uyanırdım oyuna koşmak için
yemeğimi Oyun oyuna tekrar geçmek için
oyun oynamak için yerdim okula yaptığın
her şey Eninde sonunda oyun içindi benim
herkes gibi
ama çocuklar
Grup oyunlarında çok iyidir takım
oyunlarında Şahane eder bazı çocuklarda
tek başına oynadığı oyunlarda çok iyidir
Ben iki
fena değildim iyiydim ama tek başıma
kurguladığım dünyalar Çok etkileyici ve
benim için çok çok büyük olurdu yani o
günden belliymiş Aslında ne olacağım
benim sanıyorum
Ve benim şu an Mutfağım Gerçekten mavi
dedim yani orada ben
Dinleniyorum orada üretiyorum orada oyun
oynuyorum Orası benim her şeyim
misal şu gördüğünüz enginar Şimdi ben
tam bu şu anda bu enginarın çıkması
gerekiyordu etkileyici olması için ama
içeriden hemen yansıttılar
etkilenmediniz
enginar
ın baktığınız zaman enginar
ne farkı var bizim çocukken kurduğumuzu
büyük kocaman dünyadan Çünkü bunun
arkasında o kadar fazla şey var ki ben
fotoğrafa baktığımda ya da enginara
baktığımda sadece enginar görmüyor
onun tohumunu görüyorum tohum kafiliniz
oluşunu görüyorum filizi olup göğe
yükselirken harcadığı o gücü enerjiyi
görüyorum çiftçiyi görüyorum ya bunun
için her damlatan çiftçiyi görüyorum
ve ondan sonra da bu enginarı aldığımda
eve Getirdiğimde ona saygı duyuyorum
şifasına saygı duyuyorum Her şeyi
bırakın bir tarafı ve enginar
enginarlıktan geçmeden amacım onu şahane
bir yemek haline getirmek oluyor
işte böyle bir yemek haline getirmek
oluyor bu benim yaptığım yemeklerden bir
tanesi
20 yıl önce arttır rektör ve sanat
yönetmeniydi 20 yıl önce de mutfağa
doğru evrildi hayatı ve bütün
yeteneklerimi eğitimimi bir de üzerine
lezzete ekleyerek oyunumda yürümeye
başladım Benim oyun O yüzden
topraktan tabağa Oradan da fotoğrafa
kadar giden bir oyun Şimdi fotoğraf
kısmını biraz açmak istiyorum
fotoğraf Neden fotoğraf çekmeye başladım
ya Ben yemekleri yapıyorum yeni
reçeteler oluşturuyorum onları stilize
ediyorum
manken gibi objektife kameraya
hazırlıyorum Bir de artı fotoğraf
çekiyorum neden
şimdi
20 yıl önce
bir
10-16-17 yıl önce falan yani ulusal bir
gazetede gastronomi sayfası hazırlıyorum
ve yönetim kurulunda da Levent Gültekin
var Belki Bu salonda olanlardan
bazılarınız bu ismi çok iyi tanıyor
bugün
ama o günden o isimle ilk defa
karşılaştım ve hayatımda da hiç
görmemişim bir toplantı istiyor benden
gidiyorum toplantıya
peki
Aydan Hanım diyor Biz diyor bir tane
yemek ansiklopedisi yapmak istiyoruz ve
kupon karşılığı bu
kitabı vermek istiyoruz kocaman böyle
kalın bir şey yapın bize her şey olsun
içinde diyor
Ben şimdi böyle duruyorum diyorum ki her
şey olmasın içinde belli başlı
başlıkları olsun Ne güzel olsun tamam
kalanı da bir şey olsun ama asılıyor ve
de olmasın bu ansiklopedi olursa bir
kurulu lazım yazı kurur lazım denetleme
lazım Bir sürü bir sürü lazım oldu lazım
Hadi gelin diyorum ben size bir
ansiklopedi değil de bir rehber yapayım
yani onu yapayım bugüne kadar da hiç
kitap yapmamışım bugün baktığımda arkaya
8 tane 9 tane kitabım var hepsinde
kendim yapıyorum noktasına kadar ama o
gün hiç kitabım yayınlanmamış hayatımda
hiç kitabım Olmamış daha bir tane kitap
yapmaya karar vermişim on
da da şunun çektiği fotoğrafları
beğenmediğim için çöpe gitmiş
Yani biraz Aslında zor bir iş bana
verilen göre
her zamanım var dedim 15 gün dedi
yani gerçekten zihnimden böyle bir şey
çıktı Yani nasıl 15 günde ben size şöyle
bir yemek
ansiklopedisini yapacağım yok dedim yani
biz rehber yapalım bunu Bakalım artık
Allah ne verdiyse yapalım tamam dedim
çıktım eve gidiyorum uyurgezer gibi ya
Ben buna nasıl Evet dedim yani böyle bir
şeyden nasıl Evet dedim 15 günde Ben
nasıl bir kitap yaparım bu kadar büyük
Ondan sonra Eşim işte ne oldu böyle
böyle yaparsın dedi
nasıl yaparım eşimin
yaparsın dedi ya fotoğrafları Ben
çekersem nasıl çekeyim Ben fotoğrafçı
değilim ki fotoğraf çekip yapayım
bunları ben dedi Hadi dedi Yürü
gidiyoruz Eminönü'ne
bir tane fotoğraf makinesi aldırttı bana
bir de yetmedi üzerine kendisi 3-4 tane
lens aldı bana verdi diyorum ki alma
alma çöpe gitmesin paralar Yazık çünkü
ben ne yapacağım Ne yapamayacağım belli
değil
yaparsın dedi ertesi gün sabah baya
kalktık bana ders veriyor Çok iyi bir
fotoğraf çok iyi eski bir gazeteci ve
çok iyi bir fotoğrafçı teknik şeylerle
sizi şimdi sıkmayayım işte İso doydu
buydu her şeyi bana anlatıyor Ben böyle
baya yeni bir dil öğrenir gibi Fransızca
öğrenir gibi böyle bakıyorum falan Neyse
makinayla da kafa gözlü yara yara
denemeler yapmaya başladım
Neyse ben sabahtan akşama kadar
çalışıyorum yazıları işte biriktiriyorum
bütün arşivlediğim reçetelere çıkardım
falan filan derken İşte
25 gün sonra masanın üzerine 600
sayfalık yemek rehberi diye bir kitabı
koydum bitirdim
bitirdim 25 günde bitirdim ama kitap
maketi Ben mi bittim Orası biraz karışık
sonra
bir şeyler tetikleniyor benim böyle
vücudumda Hani bu hikayeden sonra o
kadar yorulmuşum O kadar O kadar
bitmişim ki uykusuz geçen günler işte
böyle
beceremediğim fotoğrafları için
becerebilmek için çabaların falan beni
tüketmiş Diyorum ki geçer geçmiyor Aylar
Geçiyor geçmiyor geçmiyor geçmiyor
geçmiyor Bu arada daha da kötü oluyorum
bayağı böyle yolda yürürken duvara
toslıyorum
vallahi
Yani abarttığımı düşünebilirsiniz duvara
dosya tarafta da kaşımı patlattım duvara
tostladım işte çekim yapıyoruz elimde 30
kiloluk falan böyle bir şey var aniden
böyle fişim çekilmiş gibi oluyor pıt
bırakıyorum 3 tane ayak parmağımı kırdım
vallahi
Doktorlar tetkikiler ne oluyor bana
neler bitiyor vesaire falan derken
yanlış teşhis koyulmuş o aralar yanlış
ilaçlar verilmiş Ben 42 kiloya düşmüşüm
böyle işte yazılarımı falan böyle
yaptığım yerden tak tak yazıyorum O
yazılar yazılacak çok önemli bir görev
gastronomi sayfasını yapıyorum
Türkiye'nin ilk gastronomi sayfasının
teslim edildiği kadının ondan önce hep
köşe yazıları eklerde tariflere mahkumdu
kadın yazarlar hep böyle gastronomi
sayfalarını erkeklere verirlerdi büyük
gazetelerde ilk bana vermişler çok
Ciddiye alıyorum ama öleceğim gideceğim
ben hala takka da takka'da
yazılarını yazıyorum neyse
sonra akıllı uslu bir doktora denk
geldik Gerçekten ben artık elden ayaktan
gitmişim buldu veya reaktif hipoglisemi
hastasıyım ve böyle hani yanlış ilaç
kullanmakta Şeker hastası olmaya ramak
kalmış kalp krizinden burada
gidebilirsiniz o kadar kötü hemen dedi
ilaçlarınızı bıraktırıyoruz Hemen işte
sizin dedi iki tane seçeneğiniz var ya
dedi size bir ilaç vereceğim
onunla dedi şey yapacaksınız
yemeklerinizi yiyeceksiniz Ama bir gün
şeker hastası olursunuz olmazsınız onu
bilemem ama eğer dedi şekerli
hayatınızdan çıkarırsanız şekeri
hayatınızdan çıkarırsanız o zaman dedi
hiçbir şey olmaz size iyileşirsiniz
sağlığınızı uzun bir zamanda
kazanırsınız ama iyileşirsiniz
hangisi dedi
o kadar korkunç günler geçirmişim
ölümden dönmüşüm ki ben şekeri
bırakıyorum dedim söylediğim şeyin
verdiğim kararı bu kadar zor
uygulanacağını bilmiyordum onu
uygulamaya başladığımda korkunç
sıkıntılar çektim Hiçbir elimde referans
kitap çalışma yoktu bundan 18 yıl
önceden bahsediyorum bugün şekersiz
diyebiliyoruz Bugün bunları
konuşabiliyoruz ama o gün hiçbir şey
yoktu olmadığını gördüm Türkiye'de yoktu
Londra'ya gittim ilk böyle fırsatım oldu
ilk ayaklara ayağa kalktığımda orada
portabello diye bir yer vardır belki
bilirsiniz Muazzam büyük 2 tane yemek
arşivi olan iki kitap evi vardır Yok
böyle bir kitap yok Yandık bittik
eve döndüm ve o gün karar verdim benim
bu çektiğim çileği Yani bu araştırırım
araştırıyorum bir üniversite bitirmiş
gibi okuyorum Ediyorum gıdaların
glisemik indeksleri o bu çok detaya
girmeyeceğim toparlayacağım Çünkü biraz
sonra konuşmamı
ve buna bir kitap haline getiriyorum
işte şekersiz de böyle hayat buldu
şekersiz diye bir kitabın var beni
tanıyorsanız birazcık internetten
bakarsanız
uluslararası ödülleri bol olan muazzam
bir
rehberdir kendisi yol rehberdir Şimdi
benim ürettiğim her proje Her kitabın
bir nedeni var Hayatımın bir kesiti
hayatımın bir özeti
bir zaman
bu oyunda oynarken
İlla başrol olacağım demedim illa
başkasının ne yaptığına bakmadım hep
kendimle yarıştım
çok önemli bir toplantıya giderken çok
önemli hayatımı değiştirecek bir
toplantı bunu yaşadım arkadaşlar çok
önemli iki gün önceden hazırlanmışım
Elim ayağım titriyor heyecandan çok
önemli bir fırsat ya Yani onu Eğer
yaparsam Kariyerim değişecek
zıplayacağım
yolda kaza geçirmiş bir kedi görüyor
duruyorum alıyorum bu birebir yaşandı ve
yaşanacaktı
toplantı Toplantı bitti o kedinin Artık
hayatta kalma mücadelesini ortak
oluyorum yan rolde oluyor başrolde değil
umrumda değil hayat bana ne getirirse
hayat bana ne sunarsa oraya evriliyor
misalia misafirim gelecek ıspanaklı bir
yemek yapacağım ve çok önemli O
ıspanaklı yemek benim için hayati yani
onu yaparsam 10 tane Yıldız 5 tane
Yıldız alacağım ve hayat boyu
unutmayacaklar çok da önemli ağır bir
misafir geliyor yani onu yaparsam Ben
hayat boyu unutturmayacağım onlara
lezzetini fakat gidiyorum ıspanak yok
ıspanak en son bir tezgahta buluyorum
sürmüş gitmiş berbat ve ıspanak inat
etmiyorum onun yanındaki kereviz
de sevmem Çok da fazla insan sevmez onu
alıyorum onunla Kendimin de sevebileceği
bir yemek hazırlıyorum Yani şunu demek
istiyorum Hayat hepinize
bir sürü farklı pencereler açacak
biliyorum eminim Çünkü hepimiz oluyor
herkesle oluyor
pencerelerden Kaf şöyle uzatmadan
geçmeyin Hayat size onu getirdiyse Eğer
oradaki manzaraya bir bakın kokusunu bir
koklayın sonra nasıl evrileceği Belli
olmaz Hayat yani oyunu oynarken
karşındakinin kartını tahmin etmek ve o
tahmininin doğru çıkması muazzam bir
duygu ve hep kazanırsın ama her zaman
böyle olmayabilir
[Müzik]
ıspanaktaki hikaye biraz önceki inatla
ıspanak arayıp o Pörsümüş ıspanağı alıp
yemek yapsaydım Muhtemelen çok başarısız
bir yemek olacaktı
yapmadım hayat bana ne çıkarırsa ne
getirirse saygı duyarak malzemeye saygı
duyarak insanlara saygı duyarak her şeye
saygı duyarak en önemlisi hayata saygı
duyarak ve hayata güvenerek
adımlarım hep böyle yaptı o yüzden
lütfen siz de
bundan sonraki
hayatınızda Hayat size ne çıkardı bir
bakın başınızı kaldırın
çok çok Alakasız bir şey Belki yolunuza
çıkaracak kabul edin
her şeyi Sevin her şeye Saygı duyun
yolunuz
hep iyiliklere hizmet etsin
ahlaki değerleri yüksek
çok güzel çok başarılı hayatlarınız
olsun hepinizin dinlediğiniz için çok
teşekkür ediyorum sağ ol Sağ ol
Sağ ol